So once you've found your startup, let's say, you can actually get access free of charge
to these supercomputers.
So this is fantastic and this is something that we also pass on to a couple of the better
approaches.
And today we'll be dealing with Leonardo, number 10, the top 500 list.
That might maybe change because the top 500 list is updated every six months.
So that will be updated in June, again, so maybe it's a dropout of the top 10, but now
we can still say, we can still claim to be on one of the top 10 supercomputers.
Okay, so how does that work?
Well, we're a bit behind schedule and I promise I won't take too long but just to give you
a rough idea.
So once you log on to one of these HPC machines, you end up on what is called a login node.
So you don't want to do, you don't ever want to do any heavy lifting there.
So no number crunching, no heavy compute on the login nodes, otherwise you'll get an angry
email from the system.
Well, in your case, that will be, we'll get the angry email, so we don't want that, so
no number crunching on the login nodes.
So the login nodes are there to just prepare your scripts.
You can download the models that you need, just get ready for the actual work that needs
to be done.
But once you're actually ready to fine tune a trainer model, you want to use the compute
nodes.
These are the ones for the number crunching and these are also the ones that have the
GPUs available.
How do you connect at all to one of these login nodes?
Well, this is usually done through SSH and this is also what you'll be using here.
So through the Linux command line.
So just in case you don't know what SSH is, well, with that you create an encrypted tunnel
to the machine, in this case to one of these mentioned login nodes, where port 22 is listening
by default.
And basically, you can also use this to transfer your files.
So in case you need to transfer files, instead of SSH you use SCP, but that's the same protocol
behind that and you might want to copy stuff to and from the machine.
This is how you do it.
Basically to connect with SSH, you can connect to any of the login nodes.
Leonardo's got login 1, 2, 5 and 7 for whatever reason, I don't know, the Italians can't
count.
I have no idea what's going on like that.
In case you want to keep that random, you can just say, okay, login and leave the rest
away, login.leonardo.chinica.it, then you'll just be assigned a login node that's got
the most space available.
But just in case you want to work with, there were tools as Tmax for example, then you might
actually want to know on which login node you end up on and then you choose your login
node.
Okay, usually, by the way, you need the two-factor authentication, so in case you're a regular
user, Leonardo wants to become one, you've still got that hurdle to take, not in this
case, because these are basically trained usernames that you'll get.
Okay, when it comes to software, there's some pre-installed software, HPC, but we usually
do not recommend that software, the reason is that the software stack is not maintained
as regularly as it should be, so you'll probably want to create your own environments.
When it comes to environments, we usually recommend PXE, in case you don't know PXE,
PXE is just a fantastic package manager, it's insanely fast, because it's got that insanely
fast dependency solver programmed in Rust, if you know UB, PXE is a lot like UB, so that'll
probably be the weapon of your choice there.
Alternatively, you can work with containers, HPC systems do not use Docker, the reason
is that you don't get root access, so instead you can go with singularity, or sometimes
it's called app-tainer, depending on which vendor it's from, basically you can pull any
Docker container, so if you have a Docker container already out there, then that's super
useful, the reason why these containers are used on HPC is because they give you one large
file, so you've got everything in that large file, not like with the environments where
you've got lots of little files which parallel file systems don't like that much, but other
than that, personally I'd go with PXE more than these containers, if you have, as I said,
a finished Docker image, then it's easy to pull, really easy to do, as well as you can
see here, but if you want to build your own container, it takes some time, so yeah, I
could go with PXE in that case then.
Okay, so then how do you send off the job from the logger nodes to the compute nodes?
Well, you do this through a slum script, a slum script is basically a batch script with
some extra parameters, but we might ask what is slum, well slum is just a scheduler that
you have on these machines, because usually if you send off the job, you end in a queue,
depending on how much resources you need, for how long you need it for, you end up in
the queue, and as soon as the resources become available, your job starts to run, so that's
what slum is for then.
So right at the top of your batch script, you've got these parameters for slum, these
are not commented out, so that's how it's supposed to be, with hash as batch, so these
are all the directives that slum gets.
So what you need to mention there is the partition that you're working on, so that will always
be on the booster partition on Leonardo, these are the ones with the GPU, so these are the
ones that you need.
Now we've got a reservation in place, that's why we've got a reservation here, s underscore
trial underscore ncc, with a reservation that means you can stick the queue basically, so
we have got 100 GPUs in place, these GPUs are arranged in what is called a node, so
one node has got four GPUs on Leonardo, and essentially what that means is we can say
per team you've got one node available in the reservation.
Now make sure that you do not use more than one node in the reservation, otherwise that
would be unfair, let's have fair play and all the same chances, so per team one node
is fine.
If you want to use more than one node, you can actually also do so, and just comment
that out, the reservation, and you'll end up like every other Leonardo user in the queue,
so that means you might have to wait a little bit until your job begins to run, it might
be a long time, it might be a short time, you never know, actually on the weekend it
shouldn't be too bad, but you can try it out without the reservation as well.
So here in this case, in this slums group we chose just one node, we chose just one
task for this particular node, and only one GPU for this task, so this is a one GPU job.
We asked for 120 gigs of memory, now this is not the GPU memory, bear in mind, so that's
not the VRAM, that's the regular RAM, so on Leonardo we say okay, allocate that fairly,
so basically take 120 gigs per GPU that you have, so you can go up to four times that
amount if you have four GPUs, and by the way the GPUs of Leonardo have 64 gigs of RAM,
there are A100 GPUs from NVIDIA with 64 gigs of RAM. Okay, the CPUs per task,
yeah, it's also you can multiply by the number of GPUs that you have, if you only have one
GPU then you can again first share and take eight of these CPUs. Now if you are outside of the queue
don't forget to set the time, because actually also do it inside of their reservation as well,
always set the time, it's just a good practice, the reason being is depending on how long you
think that job will run for, you get through the queue quicker or not, so if you do not set the
time, SLURM assumes that this job will run for 24 hours, and then you might be waiting for quite
some time, so always just for good practice make sure you set the time, as a matter of fact on,
yeah, as a matter of fact within a reservation actually if you do not set it, that's within
the reservation, the job will stop after 30 minutes because that's the cutoff time, okay,
so make sure you set that time before you send off your job. Okay, so what you have then after that
is just what you have in a regular bash script, so for example in this case we want to use our
pixi environment, and we want to run something with this pixi environment, which is to define
that here in an extra variable, you do not need this manifest path to the pixi environment,
if you have your pixi tunnel within the folder that you're working in, where that
job script is as well, so only if that pixi environment is somewhere else you need to provide
the path to that as well, and then of course you just run your python script or whatever you like
to run, this is how it would look like with a singularity container, so very similar, you execute
that singularity container and you provide the image of this container, so if you use more than
one GPU, okay, how would that look like? Obviously we'd set this to two, we'd increase the RAM,
we'd increase the CPUs, the rest is the same, how about if we go to four GPUs, well you might have
guessed it, just these three numbers change accordingly, what about if you want to use more
than one node, well in that case as I already mentioned, and it's just because you'll get the
slides afterwards, make sure that you get rid of this reservation, it would be unfair otherwise.
Okay, just some useful slowing commands in case you've never worked with slowing, so with sbatch
you send off that that slow script, by the way there's another way you can also use your compute
nodes that's interactively, instead of sbatch you'd write srun and then you provide the resources
that you need, including also the time that you need that for when you get an interactive
session on a compute node. Now once you send off a job with sbatch you want to know is it already
running or not, so what's going on, so you could check that with a queue, with sq minus minus me,
that lets you know whether your jobs are already running, and you can also have a look at the
output just while it runs, if you want you can split the standard out and standard error, if you
don't mention where these files should go, they're just concatenated so they're within one bit,
and should you realize, whoops I need to cancel my job, you can always do so with scancel and the
job id, you always see the job id if you have a look at the queue, okay so you just provide that
job id and then that gets cancelled, and here as I mentioned srun will provide you with an
interactive session. Okay, now coming to the storage system on Leonardo, if you look into
Leonardo, by default you're in the home directory, but be aware that it's quite limited with 50 gigs,
so make sure that if you download models, or repeat that several times now, make sure that
if you download models, do this first of all in the login node, the reason is that on the compute
node you don't have access to the internet, so do it on the login node, and make sure that you
place the large files, so models for example in scratch, so in scratch you've got several
terabytes, basically the whole scratch
partition is several petabytes, so you've got lots of space there, we usually say 20 terabytes just
to give people a rough guideline, okay so put it in in scratch, please don't use fast or work,
that's also available if you check out the Tineca documentation, but for this particular
project this is already in use, so please make sure that you don't don't use that,
so home scratch in public is for you. Okay, when it comes to the login nodes there's a
CPU time limit as well, that is 10 minutes, so if you need to download something that's especially
true if you are dealing with singularity containers that you want to download, models usually go
pretty quickly, but singularity containers might take some time and you might hit the max time
limit, so you could use this partition where you have four hours, just if you need to download
something for longer, okay, otherwise we've also worked out a bit of a, or we've provided a bit of
a workaround, that is if you need access via the compute nodes, I already mentioned they do not
have internet access by default, so we provide you with a proxy server on one of the login nodes,
but just make sure that you don't use that for heavy bandwidth stuff, so don't download your
models via that, okay, because otherwise it just that will just be chock-a-block, so just in case
you want to use something like weights and biases or yeah anything similar to that, that's what this
is there for, okay, so make sure to use that if you need the internet for the compute nodes,
otherwise just everything through the login nodes. Okay, if you want to read something up quickly,
we've got some Leonardo onboarding material out there that's on our website, it's on a hidden
part of our website, so you know it's the AI factory website with n slash hpc minus onboarding,
check out chapter five and six especially, that talks about these first steps and also the
software topic that I just briefly mentioned. Other than that, there's also the Ginnica
documentation, but this is much more thorough as you can imagine, but of course feel free to look
that up as well, so Ginnica being the hosting entity of Leonardo and look up whatever you need
there, and that's basically it and with that go and have fun, you will get your users and passwords
afterwards, they'll be distributed to you, so basically you'll get a link via email, right,
you'll get a link via email and once you click on that link, you'll end up on a page that wants
your name and also your affiliation, so please fill that out because you also need to agree to
the Ginnica chunks and conditions, basically you just confirm that you don't use the supercomputer
for anything naughty, I don't know, bitcoin mining or simulating nuclear weapons or whatever,
so that's what you're agreeing to there and just they just want to know who's working on their
machines, okay, so this is why you need to provide your name there. This link is unique for every
user, so once you've agreed to that and filled out that free form, you then get your username and
password and with that an already used SSH that I've shown you here, okay, thanks a lot.